hey i'm tate mcrae and today i'm with
buzzfeed i'm a huge post malone fan so
i'm gonna take this stand quiz to see
how well i
actually know him if you want to see if
you can beat my score
take the quiz in the description box i'm
really scared i'm super
bad at quizzes
okay so i'm really bad at doing my
research on things
but i love his music like i think he's
one of the most talented artists ever
and i just think every single one of his
albums have never missed they're just
so good all right first question goes
first and foremost what's postman's
birth name
okay so options are austin post post
malone david post
and doug post okay so david and doug are
just weird it's definitely austin post i
know that one okay i'm right we're good
okay which holiday was post malone born
on
i feel like a stalker knowing this
christmas
halloween valentine's day or the fourth
of july it's definitely the fourth of
july i know that
how did post settle on the name malone
it's his mother's maiden name
it came from a rap name generator it was
his childhood pet's name
it was his high school nickname i don't
think it's his mother's maiden name
i think it was actually from a rap
generator i'm pretty sure and i'm right
which state was bose malone born in
colorado
texas california and new york i feel
like he would be born in california
but i'm going to guess new york i'm just
going to see and i'm right again
god i am crushing this i've never done
so on a quiz before
what's the name of post malone's debut
single white iverson
deja vu congratulations or big lie okay
easy this one's white iverson
and i got it right again which post
malone single
went number one on the hot 100 i feel
like he's gotten so many number ones
circles better now congratulations and
wow
i have a feeling it's circles it
definitely is i got it right circles and
sunflower are his number one singles
that makes sense
true or false posts his 50 tattoos on
his body
i believe that because he has so many
tattoos i'm going to say true
oh no i'm wrong he has over 70 tattoos
that would hurt so bad i'm so scared of
needles i would hate that
i have no tattoos i put on fake ones
sometimes that's the farthest i'll go
which word isn't tattooed on post
malone's face always
stay back and tired and it's back
for sure because one year this is so
weird one year for halloween i was
actually
possible i didn't do the full
everything i just did like face tats
because i thought they look cool for the
longest time i literally wanted to get
face tattoos
and my parents were like pleased yeah so
my dad literally just like
he's a great artist he drew on stay
always and tired so that's how i know
this
which of these artists isn't tattooed on
one of post's fingers
uh the options are kurt cobain bankroll
fresh
biggie and elvis presley i'm pretty sure
he would have elvis
presley and kurt cobain but i think it
might be bankroll
fresh but i don't think this is right
i'm closing my eyes i'm doing
i'm doing veggie and i'm right i'm just
crushing this
which disney princess is tattooed on
post malone's leg bell
jasmine elsa or ariel i thought it would
be elsa because that's like a newer
movie kind of
jasmine i don't think so maybe it might
be belle i'm guessing this is belle
because like beauty and the beast is
cute and i'm right oh my god i did not
expect to get that one right
which isn't the name of a post malone
studio album
there's young and after them riches not
that
stoney beerbongs and bentley's and
hollywood's bleeding
it's young and after them riches that's
what it is finish the post malone lyric
now they always say congratulations work
so hard forgot
how they used to be hayden is one the
dedication
is two how to vacation is three and then
four my old life at the station it's had
a vacation
i got it right true or false post malone
is hair to the post serial fortune
i have no idea what this question is
no idea what i just read i'm saying true
no i'm wrong
post alone is no way related to post
cereal finish the post
lyric i'm saucin i do this often don't
go on talking
the options are i'm bawling money
jumping number two is my options right
when i walk in
jump all them jordans number three is or
else you'll be tripping
and then four is none of these lyrics
they're correct i think it's on ball and
money jumping
no oh my god i thought i got that right
okay my it's the real one is
my options right when i walk in jump all
them jordans
shoot okay lastly which artist hasn't
post malone collaborated with yet
justin bieber k lonnie quavo and rihanna
he's done
with justin and k lonnie on stoney cueva
2 it's rihanna for sure that would be an
iconic collaboration
if rihanna post malone it'll be so good
congratulations you're a certified post
stan he's one of my favorite artists so
i'm not surprised they said you wouldn't
be nothing
now there's a buzzfeed quiz saying
congratulations that's so funny
that's a good ending go check out my ep
too young to be sad i'm releasing music
all the time
so make sure you listen
you